[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited to be talking about what it's
like being an international student from
the Ukraine we have nazar Eremenko
joining us on the show hello Hey
thanks for coming on really appreciate
it very grateful that we met at the bio
captivate event and that you're doing
the nervous schoolwork which is very
exciting for those that don't know
Minerva school is an awesome
international school we had Sidney bin
Hasaan on the show just up two weeks ago
and now we have you released you're
coming up next very excited very excited
your freshman from minerva school very
interested in biology and chemistry and
you can check out our links below in the
bio let's start off with will will talk
about everything with with growing up in
Ukraine and becoming an international
student but prior to that you're born
into this interesting playground called
Earth and you see this human experiment
happening as a building with a billion
of us exponential technologies happening
what is your current take on the state
of humanity well I think it's the beauty
of like being 19 years old that I'm
still learning a lot of things and I'm
not sure that I have like a complete
understanding and I complete opinion on
what's happening but I like I spent 17
years of my life in Ukraine and I think
most of the time I was not like fully
like aware of what is happening and I
would like didn't think too much about
the problems about like what other
people are experiencing but when I moved
to San Francisco I know when I was like
started learning a lot of new things and
I like I started being surrounded by
people from all around the world and
they all shared their experiences I
think my mindset changed a lot and like
there was the first time when I actually
realized the amount of problems like
humanity has right now and I realized
that
like to get some sense of purpose in my
life I have to like choose one of these
problems that might maybe integrate into
my life and like set a goal of like
contributing to like to solution to this
problem and I like I've known for a long
time that I'm interested in biology and
chemistry and I realized that like
probably my part in this would be
something connected to science and maybe
things I can do by using like my
knowledge of science and I realized that
I'm really interested in biology
chemistry and I would like I would love
to work like in the lab maybe do
research and I realized that for me
maybe I of course not understand all of
the problems that humanity has I like
probably like have some existential
crisis from time to time that like oh
like all of these like homeless people
on the streets like maybe I can help but
then I realize that if I want to help
like if I want to actually have an
impact I have to put my psyche I have to
focus on something and I have to like
put all of my effort into this and I
realized that science of is definitely
that thing I would be willing to put my
effort in and I think that like I would
like to be useful in any of the fields I
can solve with science like let it be
like food security or I don't know like
drug like antibiotic resistance or
something like that I'm not sure it
right now but I think I'm in the process
of finding out what's my passion is and
I think I will I will be able to do this
throughout my college years the way that
you think about you know you're born
into the world in that you're gonna find
the most meaning or purpose by finding
something that's a problem and
dedicating taking it on and dedicating
your life to working in that in that
problem that's it's so beautifully said
and it does provide humans with what I
think may be the most meaning in life is
doing that process and sometimes that
process can even be as simple as you
know raising
child can be that yeah can be that
process and being a good parent so all
right so tell us about what it's like
being born when 90 mm oh my gosh oh my
gosh okay great so bored in 2000 crazy
and in Ukraine where new cradle reborns
western part of Ukraine the city next it
may be a bigger city Ivana Frankie's
maybe somebody heard but it's a city
called coluche it's 60,000 people
roughly not the biggest one not the
smallest one like in moderate city yes
I'm pretty beautiful a lot of like a lot
of like it's kind of surrounded by
mountains like we have Carpathian
Mountains to the west from us so I spend
a lot of time there
with my parents but otherwise it's a
nice City I think 60,000 yes and Susan
how did you end up picking up what you
were interested in um well my dad he's a
doctor he's an orthopedic surgeon and he
never refused to like show me what he's
doing and like take me to the hospital
and take me to his surgeries and I saw a
lot of that stuff and I think I'm never
I never been afraid of that but like the
educational system in Ukraine is built
in a way that we study a lot of subjects
at once
so for example like I had like twenty
one subject and like we have like
different classes every day so like it
was kind of difficult for me to realize
at first because maybe in the beginning
I was into history but then I liked math
but then maybe like in ninth grade I
realized that I really enjoy learning
biology and chemistry and that was a
time when I started participating in the
Olympians and I really like I realized
that it was my passion to learn this and
like most of the people when they were
learning like biology or chemistry
they're really bored and like saying
they're like it's not interesting not
useful but for me was actually like
pleasure and I spend a lot of spent a
lot of time doing that just like like
for the sakes of like I don't know
pleasure and like when I
had free time so I think like at that
time I realized that I maybe want to be
a doctor maybe want to be something
connected to biology chemistry not
entirely sure but I knew it was gonna be
in that direction but there was like a
lot of pressure from my family because
we have like doctors in my family and I
knew that it would not be a problem for
me to become a doctor and like find a
job and like go to go to the University
because my grades were pretty good so I
knew it like it would be for free
so I didn't I thought a lot about that
but then like when I got accepted to
Minerva I made my decision that I'm not
going to go to medical school because I
knew it's really expensive firstly it
I'm okay still I'm not entirely sure
maybe like maybe my life I'll take when
I can expect a turn and I will realize
that I want to do that but right now I
think that I will not because like of
their expenses and because I love
because it's really difficult to be like
international student in medical school
unless like you have a good like
background and you have resources to do
that so right now I'm not sure that will
do that I'm more inclined towards
research or any kind of lab experience
and I think that's the thing I'm
interested in the most right now
so then take us to you know your your
you have a father that's an orthopedic
surgeon so that's obviously helping you
get interested in the biology chemistry
side of things as well and so you're
picking what you're what you're
interested in you're competing in
Olympiad so what is this like you know
what is the like what is the political
and economical and social fabric like in
the sixty thousand person city and you
know becoming a top level student
teachers about that yeah sure it's I
have like a lot of thoughts in that and
I think it's nobody really cares that
much about like actual professional
development and like their lifelong
goals or like long-term goals it's more
like the people who win Olympia it's
they have more like prestige in the city
the people who like people who live when
Olympiad stay like the ones who
when national Olympians they have like
monetary rewards they get like extra
points to their final exams they have
more chances to like study in that in a
good university without paying so and
it's like a lot of you know like this
competitive spirit and for me it was
like that initially I thought that I
like I just I did it for just because my
teachers made me or just like I wasn't
that interested but then like in like
tenth grade I think I realized that it
actually is something I really enjoy and
I started participating only in the
Olympia I was interested in and there
were like a kind of limpets where I had
just like I just had to like like they
were testing my theoretical knowledge
they just like some test and maybe like
other things without like without any
practice but also I was participating in
minor academy of sciences of ukraine
which is like you have to make you have
to create a scientific project and you
have to participate and like present
your project and then like you also have
to take tests in different subjects and
that was like much more interesting for
me because it was actually involving
something practical but the problem was
that I like I'm from the I'm from I
won't say I'm from a small school it's
pretty big school but I wouldn't say
like that I had a lot of support in like
a practical sense I think my teachers
were really smart and like really nice
they were really helpful but there were
certain things they couldn't teach me
like what like experimental design or
like because these things are like
they're not part taught in Ukraine and I
never knew about them and there were
certain things like about likes like you
know sub tell things about the Olympia
tour like project development that they
could not teach me and I had to do a lot
of things on my own and I wouldn't say I
had a lot of support in that because I
like why would I ask a person who
doesn't know how to do this like to help
me I just can learn myself and I can do
things for example like how do i conduct
an interview or how to like
assign control groups like do sampling
all of this all of these things and
things and i think it took a lot of self
learning although my teacher was really
really really helpful and i think
as soon as I started like winning
Olympians I'm like getting that first
second or third place and regional and
national Olympians like my status in my
city light grew a lot and like I was
perceived less like oh he's like winning
a lot of Olympians but still I wouldn't
say that at that point I had a lot of
like thoughts about like my long-term
goals or like short-term goals I was
just like doing that because I liked it
and now I kind of regret not like doing
something like finding this specific
interest and like working in that
direction because I I like my interests
were really dispersed and they were not
like focused and although it was a great
experience I didn't I don't think that I
I got too much from that except for like
maybe I don't know like things for my
resume but that was a great experience I
think I did not regret spending like
almost all of my time on that and it
certainly like brought a lot of
attention to me and Sara Lee brought
like a lot of the same time
responsibility to me that like people
were expecting certain things from me
participate in those Olympians but I
think it's just for my benefit because I
probably like develop their
responsibility in academic terms and
like personal responsibility as well
yeah you have to teach yourself what
you're not learning from the from the
teachers from the parents from the
community and that's that's hard to
figure out what exactly that is when you
especially when you may not have an
exact focus of the problems that you
want to solve right away what was the
science project that you did for the
Academy oh yeah sure so like one of my
pictures is about that it's like it's
kind of it's a funny story because when
I was in tenth grade that I was doing
sure I think it's a third no no no not
in the third one the fourth one fourth
before yeah so like when I was in 9th
and 10th grades I was doing this like
project can like connected to water
safety in my city and I was like testing
a lot of like different water samples
like bottled water like waters from the
tap
from the worlds in my city and that was
really boring and I didn't like that was
really like it was really poor project I
still got like maybe a third no it was
the second place an original Olympiad
but still I felt like I had a lot of
like space for development and I changed
my topic to another one in 11th grade
and I found this interesting thing in
the science fair website and there was
like the about the impact of detergent
on organisms and I and I decided to test
how like different detergents impact
organisms in the soil because like most
of the waste goes to the soil and it
like maybe 20% of that does not fully go
away it just stays there and I wish I
could use the terms I used in my project
but I am not entirely sure how to
translate them into English so I I rely
I I took different samples of the soil
and I took four different types of
detergent like half of them were
claiming that they're like environment
safe for the environment half of them
were not and I was doing different like
dosages and I was mixing in with soil
and I was trying to grow pea plants in
them and then I was like watching how
California and worms were behaving and
different like dosages of these
detergent detergents in the soil and
then I was like didn't statistical
analysis like correlation and that's a
funny picture because like this is my
sister she was helping me it was like
all in my basement like minded like my
knowledge was like really poor and I
knew nothing about like sampling like
study replication and I and maybe it was
not that hard like a local or like we
even the regional regional level but
then when I came to the national
competition most of my competitors they
were collaborating was like the best
labs in the Ukraine and like had mentors
like like professors and the
universities and their projects were so
much better like I I felt like insecure
about what I did because it was
literally in the basement of my house
and like not fully adhere to the
principles of like like experimental
design but I think I
did a good job in like presenting myself
in a proper way you liked it like using
my charisma probably and like pointing
out the problems in because like you
know when we listen to others projects
we could waste hand and asked a question
so I was doing everything to like make
sure that their project like the floss
and their projects were highlighted
where and you know like usually it's the
case that people just get their projects
from the mentors and they like do not do
themselves like do not do a lot of
things themselves so they cannot fully
like present them and they do not know
all of the like subtle things but I knew
like everything about my project so
everything they were asking me I could
answer and I like presented my yeah I
was like really confident in myself and
I I did a lot a really good job but like
in a theoretical part of that and I I
got a second place which was really like
strange Herbie I did not expect that at
all and I was like really proud of
myself because all of those people who
like had beautiful experiments and like
great projects that he didn't like
actually they were they ended up baloney
so I still like have to get my like I
think they are paying me like three
hundred three three hundred dollars so
some like that I still have to go back
to Ukraine and get them because I
laughed as soon as they were like four
Minerva soon as they started sending the
money and they couldn't send it to my
parents so I'm excited about that but I
was an interesting experience and it was
probably like the only looked at the
time when I realized that I get that
like a sense of purpose from do it like
from actually discovering things like in
like the interaction between humans and
nature and maybe like drawing some like
potential consequences of that and I
realized that I really enjoy doing that
and I really would love to do that like
in maybe more controlled environment
where the person who actually knows what
they're doing and that was that was a
really like probably the experience
which proved for me that I'm interested
in that and I really like biology and
chemistry and I would love to pursue
that and future you you you give us this
really powerful way of understanding
doing a science experiment which is if
there's a method where you have a
mentor do a lot of the work and you kind
of don't really maybe get you can't talk
about the subtleties like you were
saying about the work versus even if you
do that in a lab it doesn't matter but
if you you do in your basement wherever
you end up doing it if you do a majority
of the hands-on work and understand the
experiment understand the subtleties and
you're able to talk about it and answer
the hardest questions like you were
trying to ask them hard questions to see
if they knew right I'm glad that you had
that full hands-on scream and you
actually pointed out something else
interesting which is there's with this
experiment you learned that certain
companies are gonna market certain
things that you're trying to validate if
it's true or not because a lot of
marketing and propaganda is just for
selling things consumerism instead of
truth what did you discover were the two
that you tested that were
environmentally friendly and two that
were not what did the P grow in the ones
that were environmentally friendly I
actually yes they grew better because
like I think that like the the major
difference was like in folks like
phosphates and like they are known to
like bring the most consequences to the
environment like as this like as a part
of detergents and because they did not
contain those like the pea plants and
like grew better and the more
Californian worms like state alive but I
do not think that I can like make solid
conclusions because I said that because
of like more testing know like
replication my Sam thing was not the
best I like the environment was like
changing because of the like my like my
basement was not fully isolated yeah and
like that was a lot of things I should
have done differently but still like
even even doing that I saw like there
was a difference and like there was a
correlation between like the like the
dose of the detergent and and the like
growth rate of the pea plant but like I
cannot fully said it was like accusation
like oh it was a correlation but I don't
have enough like I have enough to say
that I know should cost the different
growth rates but I think yeah I maybe I
will come back to that when it come back
because my sister she's 12
now and she is also interested in
biology and ecology and I think maybe we
can do it again maybe we can improve the
experiment we can actually they do
something differently and I can bring my
knowledge I got from Minerva this year
and helped her out with that maybe here
like I will be her mentor something like
that and you you do think that it might
be related the detergent not having
phosphates that maybe yeah there is
maybe yeah okay and then so Ron just had
a couple photos up he had the photo of
your mom and dad up actually this is
where were you guys is in France
no it's in Vienna it's in Vienna okay
cool cool and then so so dad orthopedic
surgeon mom she's an account er in the
same hospital no counter in the same
hospital okay very cool and then one
other sister you had a cyst there two
girls yeah yes she's much younger 12
okay and then the we haven't showed in
the first picture yet which we really
like the first picture is great so this
is you how old were you in this in this
picture I think I was I think I was like
eight years old seven eight years old so
like the reason why I chose this big
tribute is because like you're sure
dorable no not really but it's a nice
picture but like I like a part of my
childhood it was said I think I had a
lot of attention from my parents and all
of like like all of my relatives
basically I remember like my grandma
took me to this photo place where they
took a picture of me and then somehow it
ended up like you know like they have
this like a place where they put their
best pictures and this like this photo
place it was like in the center of my
city and they put my picture picture
there and they stayed there for like
five years
so like even when I was like 14 years
old I still could see that and like a
lot of people wear it making fun of me
but like the thing why I chose this
picture is like I think at that time was
like the part when I actually um when my
parents like played the most important
role is in my like while bringing me up
they they were like they put a lot of
pressure on me in terms of academics
and I remember even plug before I came
like I started I like I started my
primary school I already had like all of
the notebooks I was already like
learning how to like calculate things
like I started reading when I was four
and they were like really really serious
about that I remember like I was like
nine years always like in third grade I
like and vividly remember my mom like
tearing my notebooks apart when I had
bad grades and she was like like I
couldn't like leave my house unless like
I did everything perfectly like we have
a 12 grade system yeah and like as soon
as I got like can like not a level 11 or
12 like my mom got really mad and it was
really scared so like it sounds horrible
it sounds like I was abused or something
but I'm incredibly grateful for tomorrow
yeah because I feel like if they didn't
do this to me I wouldn't be like even
ten percent as responsible as I am right
now right I deserved every beat and I
got by my mother she kicked the living
[ __ ] out of me and I'm a better person
today because of that that I think I
also I also agree with that and I think
we don't really fully recognize the what
our parents do for us until we become a
little older but then was very grateful
a lot for for some of the things that
they yes and I can already see a
difference because my sister is she I
don't think they put as much effort like
they do not like I heard my mom like
yelling in her because of like that
grates maybe two times in my life
whereas for me it was like two times per
day I I think she's not it's like even
like 10% as responsible as me she's like
oh it's fine like she's definitely not
like stupid or anything yeah I love her
a lot I think she's she's really great
for her age like she's much more mature
than her peers but she definitely
doesn't care about education as much as
I do she's just like like it's fine it's
fine she I have to force her in a lot of
ways yeah yeah so I feel like that's the
difference in like the way our parents
brought us up I think probably just like
I don't know that lazy-ass neighborhood
like I don't know as I was growing up
and they didn't like they probably were
not expecting to be like to put as much
effort in her as they put in me because
I was the first child so yeah there's a
what
what's happening in the you know the
fabric of Ukraine so teach us about this
so your mom and dad are both working in
the city 60,000 people you know you and
your sister are growing up the political
sphere is a little bit it's a little bit
crazy like socio a house house like the
economics of like people do they have
enough money for you know for their rent
and their food and their you know and
like what was going on with the Russia
intervention in Crimea and stuff like
that that seems like it was causing a
crazy amount of a global energy from
that yeah sure so I think up until 2014
before like the political thing with
Russia started I think that I like there
there's a lot of like like you know
social economical and inequality in
Ukraine and people who have money they
have like more access to better
education to better schools to better
like level off education like overall
and I think that that that that that is
the thing which made me sad in many
different ways because we I had I had a
lot of smart friends I had a lot of
friends who if they were born in a
better time in a better place like they
would they would I think there would be
famous because like because of how smart
they are and it's just a matter of
information access and I'm like where
you like where you live and what school
you're going to because for example if I
didn't find out about the exchange
program I want to I would never know
about like the naira I would never know
about like bigger communities so would
never know about different things I know
now and like we didn't have a lot of
like access to like exchange programs
like conferences like global problems
I don't know coding like not nobody
cares about that just because nobody
talks about this and I feel it largely
depends on the where you come from
because people who have like better X's
like about access to like like
gymnasiums or like like like higher
quality schools they they definitely
have access to that so I feel like it's
it's a little bit sad and I
really like I'm glad that I had an
opportunity to like go to the United
States and explore but when the
intervention of Russia started I don't
think that my city got really affected
with that because we live like an
opposites on Alma's inside of Ukraine
and it only touched the people who like
the guys who were like 18 to 20 like 5
years old and when they were summoned by
the military and they had to like go to
the eastern Ukraine and fight wasn't
everyone that was 18 to 20 or was a half
of the 18 to 20 not like it's it's a
really um I'm not sure because I was
like 14 at that time but I'm pretty sure
that a lot of people were like God their
draft yeah like this latter but a lot of
people try to escape that and try a lot
of people Wow you know there's it's one
thing when something like when we fight
first like something we really care
about like for example when we had the
like revolution in Kiev when it like
before when the like you know call which
like the president who refused to like
he didn't just refuse to sign the paper
which basically could put Ukraine to
like like as a part of Europe and like
make us more developed and like get like
better connections with Europe he
decided not to do that because he chose
to like collaborate with Russia and a
lot of people disagree with that and
they had a sense of purpose to like to
go to Kiev and actually like Center you
know and prove something but like in
eastern Ukraine it really it lost its
purpose really flick fast because
they've been fighting over like nothing
for like the last two years like there's
literally nothing left in eastern
Ukraine and still a lot of people go
there and like and they die I think
maybe a month ago my mom like went to a
funeral because like a guy who was like
19 years old he got shot by a sniper and
like and they're like there's a lot of
things happening like people hate like a
lot of people hate our current president
and we actually have elections tomorrow
so I'm not sure how it's worn out but
through the presidential yeah
presidential elections Wow tomorrow so
lots of food
for your position yeah yeah not that is
there a term limit to term two times
yeah only two terms and not entirely
sure how it's gonna turn out but no I
don't think my city got really affected
besides those people who didn't have an
opportunity to like somehow escape or
who actually wanted to go there because
unfortunately going to eastern Ukraine
became like a job because people get
much better paid there in eastern
Ukraine I'm not it's not even like
eastern Ukraine is just like military
they get paid like maybe four times it's
like wow people who work just unlike
regular jobs so it was not like a matter
of patriotism or like purpose it was
just because people wanted to earn my
money so and and then is is the
political party like kind of like a
two-party system and is it kind of like
a conservative and a Progressive Party
or what is it like you know so I don't
think so I don't think that I I don't
think there's like this huge distinction
we have parties but the I never had that
they had like they just you know like
they fear us with all these like we are
gonna do this and this like your life is
gonna get much better there of course
like more like radical parties like and
they're like their campaigns are like
ridiculous like you I sometimes read
then and I'm I both like want to laugh
and cry because some like the like they
said like senator mean ISM like it's the
death for the Ukrainian family and like
all these like things you know it's just
a ridiculous and I don't think a lot of
people support them so they I don't
really care because I know they're never
gonna like get any power because people
are not that like outdated but it's not
like the parties have their strong like
position and like like Republican or
democratic it's not like that it's just
like who who who gives better promises
and who yeah it's it's I don't think
it's like that it's that way all across
the board if you travel to each country
and met the government of each country
you're gonna meet the same people it's
the same collective soul that are
governing us we need to go beyond that
self-governance lose our
to be led or rule or governed so keep up
the good work and is there we're all
counting on you and then what about the
so then you you were teaching us about
these the exchange programs right you
learned that these exchange programs
exist and then the one was in DC right
one of them was there okay so this was
like Future Leaders exchange program
Future Leaders exchange it exists in a
post Soviet Union countries it was
created like 30 years ago when Soviet
Union collapsed and they like I think
was you asked the Department of State
decided to like take some of the people
from these countries and bring them to
the United States like culturally
integrate them to like prevent like
worse or like you know like future
misunderstandings between these
countries because like of course if you
like bring people together and defined
like they actually start collaborating
like the international relations like
get much better than like and we have a
lot of like I think every year 250
people from Ukraine go there so it's
like already like how many generations
went there like thousands of people and
it cranes these like bonds between
countries and like international
relations like become much better as I
have said but I initially I wonder why
when I was in sixth grade I I found out
about this program and I found out it
they sent to 250 students to one of the
US states and you live in a hostel II
for a year you go to high school you
live like a typical American teenager
and it's completely free and they pay
you like $150 type and just for your
like personal needs like once a month I
think but like a year-long program yeah
and otherwise during high school yes yes
a 490 and perfect like fright for high
school sophomores and freshmen okay
and I participate in what in ninth grade
I didn't win at that time but then I
tried again in tenth grade and and then
I pass to the last round and like you
know they have this like they choose 250
students who are gonna go for sure and
they choose 50 out
finalist we're gonna go if the students
decide not to like go and they just like
put them on their place yeah and I was
one of the alternate candidate
candidates and it was funny because I
was the last alternate candidate who was
chosen to be a final so I'm basically
the last finalist from Ukraine there was
like a matter of luck and I was really
happy to go so yeah yeah and I my
parents were yeah where did you go which
state Michigan you into Michigan yeah oh
and that's why you have the pictures of
Chicago right yeah yeah yeah so let's
yeah let's let's pulled those let's pull
those pictures of Chicago up so you had
one in front of the beam yeah but the
last one is actually from this here I
this is from this this is a skyline but
this one is from this year this one's
from this year yeah it looks like from a
two month ago Oh from two months you
revisit it yeah yeah oh the family you
were visited this yeah yeah yeah but the
goat Ronny hit us with that one with the
bean yeah the third one you had that one
so then one more back I think yeah well
we're back yeah this one so this is you
in tenth grade
yes I was I was sixth I was seventeen
actually I just turned 17 dead and who
are you with
it's one of my best friends Christina
and Julia she lived in Wisconsin we are
from the same generation yeah and my
host mother she was like amazing woman
she she took me like I cannot describe
how how great she was she was really
supportive like not because did she took
me like two different cities like I mean
even if she didn't have would still love
her a lot
but because the people that's in the
fifth photo is the host oh no that's no
no no yeah she took a picture like she
took this picture oh she did but where
I'm leading that she she knew we could
see her maybe you know um I am Not sure
okay here here and she she found out
that I have friend from Wisconsin and
she suggested to I go to Wisconsin pick
her up and to take us to Chicago and she
took us like and we spent three days
there and she paid like for us for
everything for City Pass
I wouldn't say that she's like rich or
wealthy she's like she's a single mom
she like has like adopted child with
with Down syndrome and she's a music
teacher so of course she has like enough
money to live but she I don't think that
anyone else in this like position would
like just give money to exchange student
and take them to different cities and
that was not the only time must they
have a very good soul you she something
like she adopted two child children she
she she's amazing I really she was a
great support for me and even like after
that she took two of my other friends
who stayed in Michigan as well in South
Carolina and she took us to all all the
way down to Florida
like she drives she drove there and she
we stayed in hotels she paid for
everything they just we paid for like
Orlando Harry Potter Park we went there
together and we have just a page for our
tickets but otherwise she paid for
everything and there was amazing time
and like I really appreciated that yeah
yeah okay so then the exchange for me
did for a year
okay in Michigan and then then you came
back and you were succeeding at the
Olympiads and everything and then you
decided that you wanted to apply to the
nervous schools and the minerva schools
acceptance rates extremely low there's
only like a hundred fifty kids per class
that get in and it's an international
school you would you guys were teaching
me earlier that you come to San
Francisco for your first year and then
you spend one semester in Seoul and and
India and then Argentina and then in
Taipei Taiwan and then in London that's
so awesome
that's so awesome what a cool way to
like learn about the cultures around the
world and okay so then how did you end
up figuring out that Minerva schools of
what you wanted to do and that that's
how you you know decided to apply and
then all of a sudden you're here so I
yeah I found out about Minerva like very
randomly I was just scrolling through my
feeding Instagram I think like 2 a.m.
and then I
it was like I think it was August of
2016 and I just like randomly saw so one
of my friends and like I think she
posted something in her Instagram story
and I like replied to her and she told
me that she was like preparing her
application materials from Minerva and I
was like what is Minerva and she told me
about that and I researched and I got
really excited i I I realized that
that's a school I'm I would love to
study in and like the whole concept was
so interesting for me but I didn't have
any hope I just I saw the acceptance
rate and I just said okay I would just
apply like you know nothing but it could
happen and I chose the binding
enrollment which is like if you if you
get accepted you have ten days to decide
and you cannot like you cannot go to
apply to any other University so I think
was October 10th and I received my like
I received my email about the applicant
like about the decision and I remember
it was like also 2 a.m. or something and
I heard my like this the noise of like
you know one email like when you get a
mail from somebody and I I can't really
I I didn't think it was my decision I
was just like I just thought it was
something for my Flex or something that
and I got out of my bed and I checked
and I saw it was from Minerva and then I
checked and I opened and the like it
doesn't just like give you a letter they
like you open it and there's like a
video which was really confusing at that
time because I was really like surprised
and then like gladder appeared and I
realized that I got accepted I was like
I was shocked like I'm like I couldn't
like type might like my hands were
shaking well then I woke my parents up
and they died they didn't really realize
what happened and they just probably
realized like a like weeks after but
then I didn't really get I didn't like I
tried to not get too excited because I
knew that I haven't received my
financial aid back yeah yeah so I had to
like I if I didn't get a financial aid I
would probably not be able to study with
yoga so I I still risk took a risk and I
paid money for enrollment and I was
waiting from our financial aid there was
a lot of struggles with that but in the
end
was okay and I realized that I'm going
to go to the Nerva and that was that was
I think was one of the happiest moments
of my life and I got the letter but then
like I was really interesting and now
you're with a hundred and fifty kids in
your class that are 19 from around the
world and what is it like you know
you're in you know you're in San
Francisco now it's gonna change as you
go from city to city but you stay with
the same hundred fifty yes yes you're
doing you do online courses so you have
you have you have online online courses
just like an online school but at the
same time you're you know interestingly
your classroom is just full of yeah
people from around the world so yes to
tell us about what this is like thanks
Ron so it's it's interesting like we all
live at the same space so although they
are all from the different like from
different parts of the world like I can
see like their backgrounds and I know
they're like two floors above me or
something that so I it's it's a great
experience I a lot of people went to
here online school d like they take it
not seriously but like it's all life and
like our professor in like asks us a lot
of questions we work in groups we answer
the polls we like there's a lot of
activity and if you come to the class on
a prepared you will definitely not be
able to go through the class because of
the amount of times the teacher will ask
you like directly and it's not like that
you can just come and prepare like we
have a lot of preparation for each class
and it's like basically self teaching
and because we discuss a lot of things
and um we just like get some feedback
during the class yeah and the site we
don't have tests so we have like the
assignments a lot of them are a location
base we have to go out like to the city
and work with like go to like different
places that's gonna give us some
examples of where you go oh so for
example like in like the last year we
were learning about utopian like
dystopia in the energy model
communication course and we had to
choose one of the attract like one of
the sites in San Francisco and we had to
go there and observe it for five hours
like see how people interact with it and
why like at 1500
four words paper about what elements of
utopia and dystopia displace very so I
think for example like a week ago I had
to make a survey in the city and I had
to like like create a hypothesis about
why people aged and like for example my
hypothesis was like people like who like
you if there is a correlation between
like the amount of time like amount of
time people use social media and amout
of like times they exercise like for
example if they use social media more
exercise less then like we have a more
prone for like certain diseases and they
have like lesser life expectancy so I
had to go and ask a lot of people and
like make them take the survey and that
could like involves a lot of a lot of
engagement of this with the city and
that's like the same with every city so
there's project-based assignments that
you go out into the city yes that's so
great that hands-on like experimenting
and hypothesis and testing this is so so
important yeah now now with them what
have you learned from the other students
from around the world that you get to
hang out with oh like a lot of things
like i i i think i discover a lot of
amazing things and especially with like
the people I hang out more with like I
have two best friends like a guy from
Uruguay and the girl from Hungary and we
like to travel a lot together and it was
really interesting for me to find out
about like the things which happen in
their countries yeah like the thing
who's like are happening and Hungary
right now with like the dictatorship
and I never like I never knew about that
before and like I never knew a lot about
Uruguay and I don't think I have like
certain examples about they're just like
a lot of mesmerizing things like for
example I never knew like Alicia told me
like two weeks ago that for example in
China a lot of like they don't usually
use like cash money and like even the
people like the homeless people they
have the QR codes yeah to like ask for
money and I was like that's so easy to
say you know I never like I never even
like have an idea about this so like
never had idea and I I know that there's
so much more to learn from those people
and that's like I think
the best part about living with people
from the 50 countries and they're all
different they all have beautiful
personalities every every week we have
malaria Botox so people from like like
present their own like but like present
themselves and then we have like ten
ones where like people present their
countries so it's like a lot of new
information and like great time
so Minerva talks is where you guys give
presentations about your upbringing and
and and who you are to the rest of the
class
oh such a good idea yeah that's awesome
and we have the IBEW every week every
week like have to sign up and there's
like five presentations well not really
it's no no not really it's every week
it's one person because we have one
because we have five years oh four years
oh you're four years and like every week
I think yeah yeah yeah that's true
interesting that's that's so cool I love
I love the way that that you that you
explain that if you have a friend from a
different part of the world and you ask
them questions about who they are what
their life was like you can learn so
much about the world through their
experiences around the world and it's
much I think it gives you a deeper
potentially source of information than
just reading an article about about
something about some part of the world
you can get that first-hand experience
from someone else and I think that's
very beautiful and then okay so it's
interesting biology and chemistry just
exploring continuing to explore one of
the things you mentioned the very
beginning was very cool was that you
want to find the problem and you want to
work towards it every single day that's
a very beautiful thing that will
definitely bring lots of meeting
purposively
in life what would you say has been a
big takeaway for you in this generation
you know you're born in 2000 you have
you've had the phone since you were a
kid you know you've had access to the
internet since you were a kid so to the
unlimited amount of information what do
you think has been a big takeaway for
you growing up in the
with your generation in this age um well
I think that all of us are really
privileged to have like access to the
information we have and like for example
my dad kept telling that to me a lot
when I was a kid that when he was like
10 or 15 years old he had to go to the
library and like learn a lot a lot about
things just like from limited sources
and now like that I have so many
opportunities it's I feel like the
biggest takeaway is that a lot of people
misuse and they do not take the full
advantage of what they have and
especially back in my city people mostly
use internet for social media and like
wasting their time watching YouTube but
then there's so much more than that
yeah and all of their like internships
I'm looking for all of the information I
found I find all of the like things
which which are interesting for me it
just takes like five seconds to google
it and I I realized that maybe like
three or two years ago that I don't want
to lose this opportunity and I don't
want to I don't want to I want to take a
full advantage of the like access I have
and I've been like looking for all the
conference's about like opportunities in
my country and like even organizing
projects it's so much easier now to like
involve people because so I because of
the access to social media and I can
like gather so many people like you know
the idea is so much easier and like I
think it's it's beautiful that I have
this opportunity and it's really sad
that people do not really use it like
maybe in the United States they kind of
some of the people do but in Ukraine not
at all and I feel like there's there's a
lot of things to explore there's a lot
of things to share and I feel like I
never knew about coding and I thought
like I had a lot of misconceptions about
the coding and I'm gonna understand such
an interesting thing and I can go back
to Ukraine and like make a small
workshop which can like change like pee
twice as many people and that's I think
it's really it's amazing that I can like
I have this opportunity that's the way
to use technology go and learn about a
skill you set up a
a group where people can come and learn
about that skill that's a great way to
use it and there's a lot of distractive
things that are that are edging into
that we need to push away and focus on
what the signal is or you do you have
any concerns about artificial
intelligence or synthetic biology or
brain computer interfaces or any of
those things and do you think that the
generation Z can can tackle those
challenges um
well of course like I don't think that I
like I constantly think about them just
like simply because I feel like there's
there are much more more serious
problems which are approaching and like
I think they should be cared about the
most right now but of course like IH
ones which ones other I don't know like
global warming yeah climate change and
like food security and like
overpopulation and like antibiotic
resistance that like these are the
things which are like sometimes terrify
me but of course I think that yes there
are potential risks and even in the
narrow we had like this part when we
were thinking like what we were
discussing whether cloning is ethical or
not and I thought a lot about this and I
realized that yes there are risks but
risks like there would be in any like in
any case they are everywhere and it's
and I think I can participate in like
mitigating these risks when I like
actually have an opportunity when I
actually become applicant part of the
network of people who love them like
have control over certain things and I
don't think I can like do a lot now
because there is there's not like no too
much like dangerous from like from the
things people are doing right now with
science but of course it can go wrong
easily and I don't want to discuss like
the problems which are not like
impacting a lot of people right now it's
interesting that you put food security
as a more of a major problem than like
AI in synthetic biology and stuff like
that dog very interesting right now yes
of course like maybe maybe in future
that would be much interesting like much
more serious problem was like this
modern thing that more people are dying
because of that artificial intelligence
right now there's general food security
here so I think like we have to like
tackle the problems which are feasible
right now instead of thinking how can we
solve the problems which will happen
like in 50 years because why would we do
this we should like who knows who knows
who knows who if we will survive until
like 20 and 50 if we keep like doing the
things we are doing right now so what
yeah we have to grow up ethically and
morally in many ways this our couple
questions ok yeah sure
first question is are we alone in the
cosmos well I I really don't think so
like even like thinking about the
probability what is the like what are
the chances that only like out of
lamellae are like billions and millions
of like stars in the universe we are not
aware of that we are the only ones and I
really think that we are not alone I
also don't think that we will I will be
in the new generation which discovers
there the things like the
extra-terrestrial life because I think
that we are not at the part of the
progress which will allow us to like
take the I don't know the full potential
of like the solar energy to like fly
that's far away but I think that we're
at end to believe that we are not alone
because like thinking about that just
slightly gives me anxiety and then makes
me uncomfortable so I prefer to believe
that we are not and maybe like my
grandchildren whoa yeah will be
witnesses of like some other forms of
life and then the next question is do
you believe we are in a simulation or
that's also an interesting question like
I I think I a month ago was discussing
this with my friend that like that would
be interested if we were just like an
experiment of some more like developed
civilization and you know like I'm
I think that I yeah certainly sometimes
to think about this but like even if no
matter no matter what we are and like
even if I am a part of a simulation it's
it's up to me how I live in this
simulation and I still have to work and
I still have to like do the best I can
to like get like to the goals I want to
achieve just want to level off still
yeah still want to perform well in this
generation so I don't think I can do a
lot of you know I can cannot like impact
that a lot so there are certain things I
I just want to like they're they are
hard to grasp with my mind
they're certainly interesting but I
don't think they're worth of worrying
about at this point of my life and the
last question is what do you think is
the most beautiful thing in the world
hmm what is the most beautiful thing in
the world
I at this point I I really I don't think
that I know a lot simply because I'm 19
I can just like judge based on my
experience but like they like genuine
human relations which brings so much
emotions and like events to our lives
it's really beautiful the like every
year I have I'm surrounded by different
people and every year these people bring
different things to my life and like
even interactions to like with my
parents and like knowing that I can give
to people and like for example like I
think one of the biggest goals for me is
to like earn enough money and like take
them like to like to like world tour
like just you like make them see a lot
of things and knowing that I can impact
people and knowing that like I have all
of this like people in my life and at
some point like having this purpose of
like working and maybe in future having
like ability to give not only take from
people it's really beautiful that I can
like like I can draw some purpose from
that although I think there like much
more things which like I usually like
probably I'm not aware of and like given
simple things which make me happy in
everyday life I think it's it's
beautiful to like to have an ability to
be happy and like have an ability to
like have all of the things I have and
like like to see and breathe and like
that's yeah that's amazing and I also
like I do I just like now that I talked
about this I realized that I don't
usually think about this but like when
you actually think about all of this
like people who surround me and things
that I can do I'm really happy because
of that and I I really I'm really
grateful yeah and I realized that like I
really realized that when I was in
Michigan ever had like that brother was
down syndrome and I realized that I am
so privileged to like be healthy and
have the ability and I think it's a it's
a beautiful thing that I can use my
potential to like actually help people
and like have all of those people in my
life
like lift the moments and like get the
best out of my life I really love young
smart people and there's our it's been
such a pleasure talking to you on the
show
sure thank you for coming sure we need
we need more of these really powerful 19
year olds that have that have these just
beautiful minds that are trying to
partake in solving some of the world's
biggest challenges and hustling so thank
you for that and thanks for inspiring
others to do the same sure that's my
pleasure love it love it thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we would love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below let
us know about what we talked about on
this episode go and talk to other people
about it as well going to share the good
messages here shoutout to ron vargas our
producer and director we love you very
much thank you thank you also support
Nizar go check out his links in the bio
below also support simulation support us
our links are in the bio below as well
also go and support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in hook
them up go and help them build help them
create and build your dreams manifest
your destiny into the world everyone we
love you so much thank you and we will
see you soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]